bienvenue bienvenue à tous sur
téléphiles soixante dix huit fils
écossais votre grand rendez vous
économique et aujourd'hui on s'intéresse
à un secteur peu connu du grand public
l'immobilier d'entreprise un secteur qui
ne connaît pas la crise
saint quentin en yvelines ses 4,6
millions de m² d'immobilier d'entreprise
votre territoire est devenu le deuxième
pôle économique de l'ouest parisien avec
1,5 million de mètres carrés de bureaux
alors pourquoi les entreprises
choisissent tel de venir s'installer ici
quels sont les atouts de saint quentin
en yvelines est ce que cela contribue à
créer une ville connectée intelligente
on va en parler dans un instant avec nos
invités sont des experts sur la question
mais d'abord le chiffre du jour et le
voici 5,24 5,24 millions d'euros c'est
la rémunération perçue par carlos
tavares pour l'année 2015
son salaire a quasiment doublé par
rapport à l'année dernière voilà qu'est
suscité la polémique même l'état s'en
est ému alors le patron de psa lui reste
droit dans ses bottes carlos tavares
estime avoir mené à bien sa mission
redresser le groupe
dont acte revenons maintenant sur le
reste de l'actualité économique sur
votre territoire
le zap échos a été fait par fanny pour
dijon
le mois de mars a été marqué par les
nombreuses manifestations contre le
projet de loi travail étudiant syndicats
demandeurs d'emploi et salariés sont
descendus à plusieurs reprises dans la
rue pour crier leur refus face à la loi
elle conneries il n'y a rien de bon là
dedans que celui qui trouve un seul truc
enfin vers des travailleurs qui le
disent il n'y a rien qu'on les
travailleurs doute épaulé lice pour les
patrons ont les entrepreneurs général
vol de sa suite à la grève générale du 9
mars nous avions reçu en plateau
bertrand de créer président du medac
yvelines il s'est dit satisfait d'une
grande partie de la loi travail et ne
comprend pas cette jeunesse qui
descendent dans la rue
il n'y a pas de combat entre patrons et
salariés
nous vivons une chose commune un chef
d'entreprise il n'a qu'une envie c'est
de voir progresser son entreprise et
dans douchez parce que si s'ils
développent si l'embauché que la
développer l'entreprise parce que les
patrons qui puisse le dire moi j'ai
envie de régresser mais fut le mois de
mars a mis à l'honneur l'entrepreneuriat
étudiant paris saclay l université de
saint quentin ont organisé une série de
rendez-vous pour dynamiser la création
d'entreprise comme le 10 mars dernier
lors de la journée de l'entrepreneuriat
étudiant un forum dédié aux start up ou
les jeunes venaient prendre conseil
auprès d'entrepreneurs pour les aider à
se lancer ici à l'université on organise
un certain nombre donc un atelier sur
sûr sur cette journée pour notamment
lever l'ensemble des difficultés liées à
la méconnaissance du métier d'entreprise
monter une entreprise
il ya beaucoup de législation il ya il
faut savoir aussi monter son business
plan il faut savoir rencontrer
c'est un pas remonter ses nouveaux
contrats rencontrer ses futurs acheteurs
il ya tout un aspect réseau et c'est là
dessus qu'on essaie de les aider 83
projets de startups ont émergé de cette
journée soit 10 de plus que l'année
dernière
une preuve que l'entrepreneuriat
étudiant encore de beaux jours devant
lui
autre temps fort de l'actualité
économique le mipim c'est le plus grand
salon international de l'immobilier de
l'immobilier d'entreprise comme tous les
ans il a réuni des professionnels pour
des professionnels du monde entier à
cannes alors saint quentin en yvelines
était présente évidemment l'occasion de
mettre en avant son concept de ville
intelligente de présenter le quartier du
vélodrome où d'autres projets comme
l'oméga parc le paris ouest
le mipim c'est un peu le davos de
l'immobilier autant dire que nous invite
l ont suivi avec intérêt il dit était
même christine turc et de beauregard
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes la
responsable du pôle immobilier et
services aux entreprises au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
alors vous accompagner les promoteurs
les investisseurs ou utilisateurs à
réaliser leurs projets vous avez un
terme à ces jolies vous êtes
facilitateur c'est ça tout à fait vous
allez nous expliquer tout ça dans un
instant alors de messieurs didier
wauquiez directeur du développement chez
cft développement un promoteur
historique ça vous attendez vous
exactement
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et enfin david bourne alors vous êtes
directeur de l'équipe de france sud de
jll jones lang lasalle alors pour faire
court et peut-être un peu réducteur vous
êtes un peu un agent immobilier dans le
secteur de l'immobilier d'entreprise
la commerciale heures effectivement
dédié aux entreprises vous trouver des
locataires ou des particuliers du monde
de l'entreprise est exactement des
entreprises pour le compte
d'investisseurs qui détiennent des
immeubles à louer ou à vendre
alors voilà on va faire déjà un petit
tour de table autour du mipim un ce
marché de l'immobilier d'entreprise
c'était ça a marché important pour ça
compte en yvelines c'est important d'y
être parce que vous y étiez tout à fait
donc le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et présents sur ce salon depuis
déjà presque une vingtaine d'années
c'est très important d'y être pour un
territoire puisque c'est là où nous
présentons tout ce qui se passe sur le
territoire
tous les projets qui sont à développer
et c'est très important d'être présent
puisque nous exposons sous l'égide de
paris région entreprises et si le
territoire n'est pas présent
lors de ces salons comme le simi
d'ailleurs qui se passe au palais des
congrès à paris en décembre
on peut disparaître très facilement de
la carte donc il faut toujours être
présent pour montrer l'attractivité du
territoire et surtout qu'on a toujours
des projets à développer parce qu'il
n'est pas facile parce qu'on le rappelle
que c'est quand même un salon
international il ya plus de 50 pays
présents je crois bien travaux il faut
savoir montrer ses forces et ses
faiblesses
alors est ce que c'est un marché qui est
offensif sur saint quentin en yvelines
messieurs le marché de l'immobilier
d'entreprise
c'est un marché qui le devient puisque
déjà c'est un marché qui est très stable
très une forte résistance sous les ans
et environ 50 à 60 mille mètres carrés
de bureaux aux moyennes qui vont se
louer ou se vendre auprès de
l'entreprise
donc ça devrait pouvoir d'attraction
auprès à la fois des grands utilisateurs
qui peuvent avoir des projets
immobiliers et puis des investisseurs
qui souhaitent lancer des immeubles des
promoteurs comme didier wauquiez qui ont
des projets donc c'est important
vous évoquez on le rappelle à vous êtes
fait partie des historiques pas vous
mais votre groupe
divine qui historiquement ont continué à
développer depuis les années 80 des
immeubles tertiaires
de plus en plus performant et donc
attaché à la relation avec les agents
immobiliers et la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
c'est un vaste sujet les a tous je pense
c'est ce sont déjà des trans d un
carrefour de transport performant une
implantation à l'ouest de paris
historiquement je dirais la plus
qualitative avec le dirait de tous les
dirigeants d'entreprises qui sont
souvent installé une proximité défense
via le rer
et puis peut-être un tissu urbain dans
le centre-ville de saint-quentin qui a
su évoluer
grâce au travail de la communauté
d'agglomération et des belles
entreprises dont pourra nous parlait
peut-être jll qui se sont implantés
depuis peut-être la venue de bouygues
qui est du crédit agricole qui étaient
des gros deux grandes sociétés
historiquement implanté sur 50 ans
auquel a donné un bon signal pour les
autres entreprises
est ce que christine le regard est ce
que c'est facile aujourd'hui de défendre
de de proposer à des entreprises de
venir s'installer ici sur un territoire
alors on a une grande chance sur le
territoire de 50 ans et qu'on a des
grosses entreprises historiques didier
le rappeler donc le crédit agricole
bouygues malakoff médéric est en fait
ces entreprises ont permis
l'installation de tout ce qu'on
considère comme dureau d'études comme
sous traitants dont qui ont voulu
s'implanter justement à côté des gros
donneurs d'ordre donc ça c'est très
important et ce qui est important
également sur notre territoire c'est que
nous ne sommes pas un territoire mono
filière nous sommes un territoire avec
six filières donc l'aéronautique
l'automobile la défense la finance les
assurances et c'est ce qui fait que si
on a un problème dans une des filières
ça ne détruit pas tout le système
économique de saint quentin et c'est
important puisque justement le fait
d'avoir plusieurs filières économiques
sur le territoire nous amène justement
de nouvelles entreprises ou conforte les
entreprises qui sont présentes et davie
banda vous aussi à une demande
importante
oui on a une demande importante sur ce
territoire et puis j'ajouterai qu'il ya
un cadre de vie également c'est une
vraie réussite 7 cette ancienne ville
nouvelle donc c'est un cadre de vie qui
est assez apprécié les entreprises sont
très sensibles aussi au bassin de
population qui qui qui gravitent autour
de leurs de leur implantation puisqu'il
faut que les salariés les collaborateurs
puissent se loger et c'est effectivement
une des réussites aussi de
l'agglomération c'est de ne pas savoir
seulement grandi sur l'immobilier
entreprises le développement de bureaux
locaux d'activités mais aussi avoir
installé tout un tissu résidentielle des
services qui sont évidemment aussi très
apprécié des entreprises
des services publics des services à la
personne des commerces donc tous à la
tribu alors nous allons voir tout de
suite si vos analyses font partager
parle aux eyrieux d'ile-de-france cet
observatoire régional de l'immobilier
étudie le marché
et voici ses conclusions pour l'année
2015 un reportage réalisé par famille
pour dire c'est dans les locaux de l'ot
et rieux que l'on étudie le marché
immobilier d'entreprise en ile de france
chaque année trois études en moyenne ils
sont réalisés
l'observatoire a constaté qu'avec un
parc de 50 3 millions de mètres carrés
de bureaux
l'île de france est première d'europe
mais l'offre a besoin d'être modernisé
l'attractivité économique en ile de
france
aujourd'hui un petit peu pénalisé par
l'offre de qualité voilà donc on n'est
plus dans le renouvellement que dans la
construction
aujourd'hui le parc et le parc de
bureaux parisiens et
et assez obsolète en partie obsolètes
donc pu tourner dans la modernisation du
parc qui permettra d'avoir une offre de
qualité et de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des entreprises notamment
locales mais aussi internationale dans
les yvelines c'est dans les années 90
que l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est affirmé comme un pôle
d'affaires dynamique
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien après la
défense
une preuve que l'agglomération conserve
de nombreux atouts pour les entreprises
d'abord la proximité de la capitale
puisque 50 ans est situé à 20 kilomètres
de paris
c'est aussi on l'a dit le tissu
dynamique les entreprises des grands
noms des grandes sociétés des dpe
innovantes des laboratoires de recherche
un pôle université très dynamique est
également des logements le développement
des transports mais aussi l'intégration
de saint quentin en yvelines au cluster
paris saclay devrait permettre à
l'agglomération de renforcer son
attractivité dans les années à venir
alors voilà dans ceux ci on a vu aussi
qu'on abordait se moderniser on a
entendu sur le terme d' obsolète c'est
une réalité que c'est une banque a fait
les élus ont pris conscience de cette
problématique à un petit peu moins d'une
dizaine d'années et saint quentin à
l'heure actuelle nous n'avons
pratiquement plus de foncier vraiment
disponibles pour accueillir des
immeubles neufs sur des terrains nus
mais par contre la ville se reconstruit
sur elle-même et de nombreuses
opérations donc de démolition
reconstruction des opérations de
rénovation ont vu le jour et sont en
projet c'est comme ça qu'on a pu capter
mercedes-benz france puisque cfc
développement avait pris le risque à
l'époque de démolir le siège social de
sodexo et de fujifilm pour préparer le
terrain pour l'accueil de mercedes benz
france et et surtout c'est une
c'est une problématique qui doit
vraiment être prises en compte parce
qu'à l'heure actuelle les utilisateurs
ne se contente plus de rester dans leur
immobilier mais veulent de l'immobilier
adaptés à la demande des utilisateurs un
immobilier flexible et c'est donc
vraiment on a besoin de ces opérations
de rénovation et démolition
lorsqu'on avoir un peu un immeuble qui
est assez simple qui fait un peu symbole
puisque c'est l'immeuble internationale
il a été construit en 1976 à saint
quentin en yvelines et aujourd'hui les
vides à 80% et l'agglomération a donc
décidé d'engager une profonde
restructuration le chantier devrait
démarrer à l'été 2007 avec la
construction de nouveaux bureaux
voici de nouveaux logements il faut
reconstruire plutôt que renouveler c'est
ce que vous me dites alors il faut
construire parce que le déjà les parmi
les plus grandes transactions qui sont
fait tous les ans ça concerne les
immeubles neufs ou dix immeubles qui
sont construits spécialement pour les
entreprises les entreprises jeunes
cherchent à être beaucoup plus citoyenne
avec des immeubles qui ont une qualité
environnementale elle cherche à faire
des économies avec des immeubles qui
sont moins énergivores et puis elles ont
fait face à une une double niveau
nouveauté finalement ces dernières
années des nouvelles technologies une
nouvelle génération qui s'est très bien
la propriété approprié pas renoncé ces
nouvelles technologies donc il faut
repenser les espaces de travail et les
espaces de travail qu'on a créé dans les
années 70 ou 80 noeuds
plus réellement adaptés aux besoins
d'aujourd'hui des entreprises alors
didier vos pieds vous entend ou encore
vous devez vous adapter vos aussi et
proposez votre nous avoir suivis je
rejoins ce que dit madame de beauregard
nous avons suivi l'évolution des
recherches foncières le foncier est
moins présent il ya moins de terrains
non construits en proximité du
centre-ville
donc nous avons depuis une dizaine
d'années nous nous sommes concentrés sur
l'acquisition de bâtiments anciens
d u est obsolète des huées non utilisé
et dont la valeur était proche de la
valeur du terrain
donc nous avons acquis d'abord
effectivement le terrain qui a fait
l'objet de l'implantation de la cds benz
puis ces deux dernières années nous
avons acquis deux bâtiments implantés
dans l'hyper centre qui vont faire
l'objet de l'inde un projet d'environ 24
25 mètres carrés et l'autre une
opération plus modestes de l'ordre de 6
7 mille mètres carrés on conserve les
infrastructures la partie sous sol qui l
est moins évolutive et on nous bâtissons
dessus un nouvel ensemble en général
plus gonflé plus dense jusqu'en densifie
centres urbains et pour reprendre ce que
disait david plus conforme à ce
qu'attendent les
utilisateurs aujourd'hui encore mieux
vaut mieux faire table rase et
reconstruire table rase plutôt que de
rénover très ponctuellement certains
immeubles peuvent être rénové ils
doivent avoir des caractéristiques haut
niveau de leur structure béton des
auteurs libre importante puisque
aujourd'hui des immeubles sont tous
climatisés avec du faux plancher des
plateaux qui doivent être dans des dents
des caractéristiques très spécifique
puisque les sociétés aujourd'hui
travaillent sur des épaisseurs moins
profondes que par le passé voilà il ya
plus rare de pouvoir rénover un bâtiment
plus facile de redémarrer de zéro comme
disait david pour reconstruire quelque
chose de plus dense et plus efficace
alors thermiquement plus efficaces aussi
et vous vous à vous accompagner ce
mouvement
vous pouvez encore on parler de votre
fonction de facilitateur vous avez des
leviers pour permettre ces rénovations
oui tout à fait heureux que la
communauté d'agglomération a pris en
compte dont très rapidement cessé ces
problématiques et nous accompagnons donc
les promoteurs dans leurs opérations de
rénovation démolition en
en travaillant justement sur le droit
des sols en modifiant certaines règles
d'urbanisme en permettant l'augmentation
de hauteur pour justement permettre aux
opérateurs de densifier leurs opérations
par exemple on a un projet sur le pas du
lac
c'est un immeuble de 2400 mètres carrés
qui va être démoli et sur ce foncier va
être construit un immeuble de 13 mille
mètres carrés donc ça permet aux
opérateurs de 2
que leur bilan tourne bien aussi donc en
densifiant et ça permet justement ces
opérations donc on a vraiment nous un
rôle on agit au niveau du droit des sols
on agit également dans les ffl puisqu'il
faut avoir l'accord des aisselles pour
changer les les autorisations de
foncière durba etc
donc on les accompagne et c'est vrai
qu'on a un rôle relativement
relativement important par rapport à ça
sinon les opérations ne pourrait pas ne
pourrait pas se réaliser il ya plus de
250 mille mètres carrés qui sont en
projet est ce que c'est une spécificité
à saint quentin en yvelines est ce que
c'est pour expliquer nos téléspectateurs
effectivement est ce que c'est vraiment
énorme est ce que c'est vraiment un défi
à relever dans lequel je le défie il est
de permettre à des sociétés qui veulent
s'installer sur le territoire de trouver
produits à leur mesure sans sens que la
production soit trop importante qui
viendraient éventuellement j'irai à
baisser les loyers
je pense que le théâtre de saint quentin
a bien maîtrise bien ce sujet nous mêmes
c'est à ces développements sur les deux
opérations que je viens de citer nous
nous lançons une en blanc c'est à dire
que nous allons en lancer une
construction sans avoir d'utilisateurs
identifier la personne du mètre carré
par contre celles qu'il fait 20 ou
d'autres opérations de 30 ou 40 mètres
carrés sont on va dire dans les cartons
prête à démarrer avec des permis mais
n'offrant l'objet de construction que
une fois un utilisateur
identifiés sur ces opérations la
sellette vous intervenez c'est vrai
qu'on de voile vient et c'est vrai que
les selon les projets il ya des cycles
de décisions qui sont plus ou moins long
donc il est important d'avoir à la fois
des projets dans les cartons comme le
disait didier mais aussi des projets en
production même si l'utilisateur n'est
pas identifiée pour justement répondre à
des entreprises qui ont des besoins
beaucoup plus courts besoin qu'on veut
dire beaucoup plus court terme tout à
fait que 2018 ou 2019
donc c'est important d'avoir les deux et
pour l'instant il y avait beaucoup de
projets dans les cartons mais peu de
projets un peu plus mûr lancée et c'est
la chose très intéressante qui est en
train de se passer depuis la fin d'année
dernière on voit des projets vraiment
avancer réellement et des immeubles se
lancer et c'est une très bonne chose
les projets à l'art on a des justement
ce qui est très intéressant là c'est que
on a pour l'année 2016 2017
on a deux opérations qui vont sortir en
blanc une opération en restructuration
très lourde et l'opération démolition
reconstruction de cfc ce qui est
important c'est que par rapport
justement à toutes ces opérations qui
sont lancés on a on est passé des années
2000 2000
12 à peu près où on avait un taux de
vacance sur le territoire de saint
quentin très important aux alentours de
14 15 % nous sommes descendus à un taux
de vacance de 7%
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il y a eu un
jeu de chaises musicales c'est à dire
que les entreprises qui ont déménagé
pour s'implanter dans des immeubles
neufs ont libéré leur immobilier
obsolète
les propriétaires ont pris conscience
que leur immobilier était trop obsolète
donc il fallait vraiment qu'ils se
lancent dans des grosses opérations de
rénovation démolition et grâce à ça
justement on a permis de diminuer le
taux de vacance c'est à dire que à
l'heure actuelle des immeubles qui sont
sur le marché sont occupés à 93 % ce qui
est vraiment très très important et
grâce aussi à quelque chose d'important
c'est là
la réforme de la de la redevance pour
création de bureaux qui est devenue une
taxe à partir du 1er janvier 2016 et
dont le tarif est passé de 236 euros à
50 euros le mètre carré
donc du coup ça va favoriser les
opérations qui sont justement en projet
les fameux 250000 pour pouvoir lancer
des opérations parce qu'à l'heure
actuelle sur saint quentin nous n'avons
pas d'immobilier neuf actuellement à
proposer une entreprise qui voudraient
s'implanter dans l'année par exemple
alors dans un deuxième temps dans cette
émission recevra un architecte mais
c'est vrai que la question se pose de
comment anticiper le fait qu'un parc
immobilier deviennent obsolètes parce
qu'effectivement quoi tous ces immeubles
ont été créés et j'imagine que là aussi
on avance et on s'est penché sur la
question et en fait ils sont obsolètes
des années plus tard c'est un problème
pour vous c'est une difficulté à gérer
c'est ce qui est assez intéressant pour
revenir sur les deux projets sur
lesquels nous sommes positionnés c'est
que le plus récent d'entre les deux est
un immeuble qui a été construit en 1993
à 1996 c'est très récent
cet immeuble a été construit par une
société qui l'avait finalement dédié à
sa propre utilisation est donc une fois
cette société partis ayant libéré cet
immeuble il ne trouve pas réellement
preneur
la chaussure est entrée particulière
donc
est ce que fait est-ce que c'est proxima
saint nom c'est celui de kidal et le
bâtiment c'est un bâtiment qui était
occupé par anciennement par la société
egis sur l'avenir du centre et ce
bâtiment effectivement conçu en 93 est
devenu obsolète car trop dédiés à
l'utilisation spécifique de cette
société proxima 5 cette opération qu'on
va lancer en blanc lui a été construit
en 83 donc effectivement correspond plus
à aux règles habite années 80 pour des
raisons aussi d'amiante aussi un il vous
faut dire et parce que il ne correspond
plus comme on l'a dit précédemment à des
à des règles d'occupation qui sont
celles d'aujourd'hui faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises ont des
règles d'occupation là on le voit à
l'écran l'ancien immeuble qui sont plus
denses donc on va dire un poste de
travail pour 12 13 mètres carrés
vous voulez mettre ça dans un immeuble
ancien vous n'y arrivez pas donc il faut
des plateaux plus compact avec moins de
contraintes aussi en termes de structure
et de poutres et poteaux poutres et on
ne retrouve pas dans les immeubles
anciens la capacité de mettre le nombre
d'utilisateurs suffisant et la baie de
bourgneuf vous avez des exigences très
particulière des entreprises elles
correspondent à ce que vient de dire à
didier bouquet alors il ya eu une vraie
accélération ces dix dernières années
les bouleversements technique les
nouveaux matériaux la nouvelle
réglementation les nouvelles façons de
travailler
donc effectivement c'est un mix de tout
ça il ya une exigence quand même qui est
toujours prioritaire c'est la proximité
des transports
on l'a aujourd'hui dans le centre ville
effectivement ensuite c'est des espaces
de travail qui soit le plus ouvert
possible qu'ils soient le plus flexible
possible tout à l'heure on en parle et
qui soit le plus connectables possible
effectivement les entreprises aussi ont
des exigences économiques on est quand
même dans une période un peu contrainte
donc on va chercher à optimiser la
surface occupée par les collaborateurs
mais à créer à côté de ça beaucoup d
espace de convivialité
beaucoup de moyens de travail et d'un
bureau à l'autre avec les nouvelles
technologies
donc ce sont les exigences particulières
mais il faut l'infrastructure pour ça il
faut des fonds plancher il faut oser des
profondeurs comme le disait didier de
bâtiments qui sont assez importantes et
tous les immeubles des années 70 sous 90
répondent pas forcément justement à
l'heure actuelle dans lés dans la
réalisation des nouveaux immeubles
il faut vraiment réfléchir maintenant à
l'avenir et
en fait tout ce qui était fait
auparavant des immeubles qu'on appelle
clé en main c'est à dire pour une
entreprise particulière qui donne sa
définition son cahier des charges
maintenant il faut que les immeubles
soit le plus réversible possible parce
que dans l'avenir en fait on va voir
l'appelant problématique suivante c est
ce qu un immeuble on le construit pour
du bureau ou est ce qu on le construit
pour du logement
en fait il faut maintenant rentrer dans
une ère où un immeuble construit peut
être facilement transformable en
logement même si c'est du bureau à
l'origine ou linverse et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera justement avoir des
immeubles les moins obsolète possible
pour l'avenir une grande souplesse
oui ces dépressions qui intéresse aussi
les investisseurs c'est à dire souvent
les hantent les entreprises
utilisatrices sont locataires
derrière il ya des investisseurs qui
achètent des immeubles qui investissent
des sommes assez importantes sur des
lancements d'immeubles et donc ils
doivent avoir une espèce de garantie
comme ça sur l'avenir que leur immeuble
ne sera pas obsolète dans cinq ou dix
ans donc c'est une problématique qui
elle qui est partagé par les les
utilisateurs de ces immeubles mais aussi
leurs propriétaires alors il ya les gros
investisseurs mais vous moi vous nous
regardez vous pouvez aussi investir dans
l'immobilier d'entreprise notamment
grâce aux profondes ding c'est ce que
propose une start up du territoire elle
s'appelle fond dit mot fanny bourdillon
elle a démocratisé l'investissement
immobilier c'est l'objectif que s'est
fixé fun dit mot cette start up lancée
en novembre dernier par trois
entrepreneurs est une plateforme de
financement participatif spécialisé dans
l'immobilier
l'immobilier est un investissement qui
n'était jusqu'à présent pas accessible
pour les particuliers pour monsieur tout
le monde et aujourd'hui grâce au
crowdfunding c'est possible vous pouvez
financer la construction la
réhabilitation d'actifs immobiliers dans
votre région grâce à ce
nouveau canal d'investissement internet
pionnière en la matière fait dix morts
répond à la réglementation actuelle en
étant agréé auprès de l'autorité des
marchés financiers la plateforme propose
déjà cinq projets immobiliers sur son
site
parmi eux le projet paris ouest à
maurepas avec la réalisation d'un
bâtiment d'activité de 5200 mètres
carrés au fond ne dit mot a choisi la
zone de maurepas et notamment la zone de
paris ouest
de par son attractivité avec les grands
axes routiers de l'ouest parisien
l'autoroute a12 l'autoroute a13
nationale 10 et notamment également de
par son attractivité en termes de
projets qui ont déjà été réalisés sur la
zone de paris ouest
le projet de réhabilitation
réhabilitation d'immeubles d'activité et
notamment de rénovation d'immeubles
existants
un site de crowfunding simple à utiliser
en quelques clics et à partir de 1000
euros le souscripteur investi dans le
projet immobilier auquel il croit une
nouvelle façon d'investir en court
circuitant les intermédiaires
traditionnels
nous sommes également une plateforme
indépendante puisque nous nous sommes
associés à aucun promoteur n'y a aucune
banque qui nous garantit une
indépendance totale dans l'analyse des
dossiers et dans la sélection des
projets qui que mail à la plate forme
avec un taux de rendement annuel de 8 à
12% par projet la plateforme rencontre
un franc succès pour 2016 une quinzaine
de projets immobiliers sont déjà en
préparation
voilà est-ce que nos invités sont aussi
convaincus par cette plateforme
d'évoquer quand sa famille écoutez il ya
un problème d'échelle c'est vrai que
déjà avant dé sur des projets peut-être
plus plus petit en taille
je trouve que le femmes personnellement
je trouve que c'est intéressant après le
métier de l'immobilier est un métier de
professionnel la conception de
l'immeuble est un élément primordial qui
va permettre j'irai de louer cet
immeuble cet imam nombre et ne
rapportera pas vous pouvez l'imaginer
est donc resté avec des professionnels
spécialisés pour concevoir ce type de
produit me paraît quand même une base
saine
sinon pour la partie de financements jeu
s'est passé c'est dans l'air du temps
effectivement alors ici devant vous les
connaissez vous allez rencontrer le
crowfunding oui enfin le kung fu 10 mai
d'ottawa au fond du moule est ce que
vous êtes intéressés par cette pratique
voilà c'est vrai que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est dans l'air du temps
oui voilà c'est dans l'air du temps donc
oui pourquoi pas au contraire c'est bien
puisque ça diversifie aussi tout le
panel des investisseurs donc pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas mais par contre on sait
que enfin sur le territoire de saint
quentin je rebondis par rapport au sujet
de tout à l'heure ce qui est important
c'est que on a des opérateurs qui ne
font pas un seul coup sûr saint quentin
on a des opérateurs qui sont vraiment
fidèle aux territoires
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive aussi avoir
un territoire aussi attractif c'est
qu'on a aussi bien des promoteurs des
investisseurs des conseils en immobilier
d'entreprise qui continuent de
travailler sur saint quentin depuis des
années et des années et ça c'est
important aussi pour l'attractivité d'un
territoire et ça permet en plus de gars
connaître le territoire et d'avoir un
maillage intéressant david byrne à vous
qui êtes spécialiste conseille vous
conseillerez passer par le c'est une
vraie tendance mais il faut savoir que
les particuliers ont déjà accès au
marché de l'immobilier d'entreprise
puisqu'il ya énormément de groupes
bancaires
deux groupes d'assurances qui propose
des supports d'investissement qu'on
appelle les ces pays qui sont finalement
des par deux portefeuilles immobiliers
qui sont accessibles au public à
n'importe qui comme vous et moi et donc
qui offrent des rendements d'ailleurs il
ya aujourd'hui un fort succès de ces
collectes de c'est sur ces pays de
collecte de fonds de particuliers et
d'autres investisseurs parce que
justement les rendements sont
particulièrement intéressant aujourd'hui
par rapport à la bourse aux obligations
ou à avoir son ses liquidités sur un
livret d'epargne quelconque
donc il ya un franc succès d'ores et
déjà sur ces produits là qui sont
accessibles aux pauvres en particulier
donc les deux finalement vont se
compléter et c'est une c'est une
tendance qui vient ajouter encore une
possibilité d'investissement pour les
particuliers ou d'autres structures pour
l'immobilier d'entreprise très bien
merci à vous trois d'art accepté notre
invitation leur fils et qu'on continue
avec trois autres grands témoins nous
allons poursuivre cette réflexion autour
de l'immobilier d'entreprise et voir
comment ce secteur permet aussi de
repenser la ville vous l'avez expliqué
là aussi dans ce premier tour de table
mais d'abord mais maintenant nous allons
faire un petit tour du web puisqu'on
parle de votre territoire sur le web
d'un point de vue économique et c'est
fanny bourdillon qui nous a donc préparé
cette revue de presse du mec
les échos sont revenus sur la fin du
vaste plan de rénovation urbaine aux
mureaux la ville a souvent souffert
d'une mauvaise image
aujourd'hui les anciens quartiers sont
transformés en vaste écoquartier sur
plus de 7 hectares aire de jeux vergers
et jardins collectifs cohabiteront de
passage dans la ville en octobre dernier
le premier ministre manuel valls a salué
l'action menée par le maire françois
garer c'est beau ici et il faut du beau
dans les quartiers populaires ce qui est
fait ici est exemplaire
bonne nouvelle c'est un yvelinois qui
prend la tête d'orange marque blanche et
ce versailles et de 48 ans reprend dont
le chantier de la fibre
abandonné par sfr en juin dernier dans
le 78 actu il revient sur ce chantier
majeur
l'expérience client est ma priorité je
serai particulièrement attaché à la
qualité service à la proximité avec nos
clients et au développement des usages
numériques dans elancourt magazine on
apprend qu'un nouveau grand nom de
l'innovation s'est installé dans la
commune ce faire et à ses l'ancienne
entité d'airbus groupes devenus
autonomes en 2014
la jeune société est basée à la clé
saint-pierre 150 collaborateurs y
développe des technologies de pointes
appliqués aux domaines militaire et
civil
vous êtes bien sûr tv fil 78 puis
l'écossé votre grand rendez vous éco et
nous parlons aujourd'hui du d'un secteur
important pour votre territoire qui est
le l'immobilier d'entreprise alors
est-ce qu'il l'immobilier d'entreprise
permet de repenser la ville d'explorer
de nouvelles pistes pour une ville plus
intelligente alors j'ai posé la question
à nos invités qui eux aussi sont des
experts dans leur domaine lambert godet
bonjour je vous êtes architecte vos
réalisations jalonnent le territoire on
citera par exemple australia le siège de
bois énergie services on nous parlait
dans la première partie de cette
émission merci d'être avec nous et vous
avez collaboré avec ligne city un
promoteur historique de saint quentin en
yvelines et catherine raynaud vous êtes
directrice de projet au sein de big city
et enfin julien chauveau alors vous êtes
responsable projet immobilier chez
crédit agricole immobilier total bonjour
crédit agricole qui a choisi d'installer
son premier campus à saint quentin en
yvelines dans les années soixante dix
ans 76 76 76 alors ce n'est pas un
campus étudiant on pourrait croire alors
maintenant c'est un conte plus
d'entreprises et rapide ou un peu la
différence
qu'est ce qui se passe dans un campus
d'entreprise alors nous avons voulu en
fait implanter les gens sur un campus
pour donner beaucoup plus de confort aux
utilisateurs plutôt que construire des
tours qu'on avait l'habitude de faire
comme par exemple à la défense
aujourd'hui le collaborateur un cadre de
vie un cadre de travail beaucoup plus
agréable avec des espaces verts est
beaucoup plus en lien avec son habitat
concrètes vous propose d'aller visiter
ce campus
le corpus donc du crédit agricole un
reportage réalisé par dany brillant
ce sont les premiers à avoir installé
leur campus à saint quentin en yvelines
à la fin des années 70 aujourd'hui le
campus du groupe crédit agricole
appelée skypark évolue encore un nouveau
bâtiment a été construit pour répondre à
un enjeu majeur doubler leurs effectifs
avant la fin de l'année nous sommes
d'ores et déjà à peu près de 2800
personnes regroupées sur le campus de
skate park au sein du groupe crédit
agricole
nous allons très fortement dans les mois
à venir jusqu'en septembre 2010 est
augmentée
nos effectifs puisque nous serons à peu
près 5000 un petit peu moins 1 4800
personnes qui travailleront sur le
campus skypark évidemment ça signifie
que nous avons construit des immeubles
nous en rénovant d'autres et puis
également effectivement nous augmentons
les infrastructures sky parc regroupe
désormais six immeubles sur une surface
de 11 hectares c'est aussi 250 salles de
réunions des langes un gymnase des
restaurants et depuis peu une
application smartphone qu'une
application smartphone qui permet
d'avoir des informations générales sur
la vie du campus qui permet de se
localiser à l'intérieur du campus je
suis dans un bâtiment où j'ai besoin de
chercher une salle dans un autre
bâtiment avec lequel je ne suis pas
familier
l'application va m'emmener directement à
la salle de réunion semble je sois
obligé de tourner dans les étages avant
de la trouver
les nouvelles technologies sont au coeur
de ce campus et les avantages sont
nombreux
travail collaboratif et participatif ou
encore lieu de vie agréable pour les
salariés aujourd'hui les grands groupes
copie tout des campus étudiant c'est un
campus ouvert apprenons un peu à la mode
américaine des campus américains de la
silicon valley des grandes entreprises
parce que ici si vous voulez c'est le
campus technologique du groupe frédéric
hohl et ça et donc nous amenons des
nouvelles technologies le numérique nous
transforme et doit transformer
transformer également les mentalités et
le campus à cette notion là on n'est pas
des étudiants au loin de là mais on
aimerait bien avoir cette approche
ouverte dynamique qui change de la
banque 30-17 traditionnelle et vous
voyez nous sommes ici dans un lieu qui
s'appelle un lounge vous ne pouvez pas
vous imaginer que vous êtes dans une
entreprise du cac 40 renault airbus ou
boeing
de nombreuses entreprises ont adopté la
même dynamique que le crédit agricole
faisant de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une
ville de campus voilà ils veulent de
campus alors je lâche ou une petite
réaction puisque c'est un peu chez vous
là bas c'est vrai que crédit agricole a
choisi sa pente en yngling très tôt
pourquoi alors on s'est installé des 76
parce qu'on a eu la possibilité
justement à l'époque on était encore la
caisse nationale du crédit agricole de
s'implanter ici on nous a fait venir à
l'époque avait pas de biars donc pas mal
de choses et d'infrastructures à mettre
en place
et puis campus historique nous avons
nous l'avons fait évoluer en 2000 on a
construit un nouveau bâtiment
et puis en 2014 un dernier 2014 si on a
commencé la rénovation des quand même
des deux bâtiments de 76 pour en faire
encore une fois le deuxième campus du
groupe et campus technologique du groupe
vous faites aussi bien du revenu des
entreprises et de l'immobilier
particulier des priorités qu'on sorte
d'un projet d'entreprise
alors la première chose c'est de bien
analyser l'environnement dans lequel on
travaille
l'analyse du terral à la réglementation
de façon à ce que l'on puisse répondre
le plus positivement possible d'abord à
la tente
de l'investisseur de l'utilisateur et du
promoteur et est donc le travail se fait
en commun et on essaye donc d'avoir
quelque chose qui soit le plus le plus
fonctionnel et le plus pérenne donc en
fait c'est une tâche qui est très
importante puisque en fait on doit avant
tout concevoir un ensemble immobilier
qui puissent évoluer dans le temps
répondre à toutes les réglementations et
puis surtout au bonheur de vivre à
l'intérieur donc de l'entreprise pour
toutes les personnes qui seront à
l'intérieur et donc sous l'on se rend
compte c'est que que ce soit en
rénovation ou surtout aux constructions
lorsque l'on crée à nouveau centre un
nouveau siège social
il est certain que ça apporte une
dynamique très forte à l'entreprise et
donc nous nous devons répondre à ces
programmes là en fonction d'un contexte
à dire que on construit ici à 50 ha
d'une façon différente que dans d'autres
capitales par exemple européenne puisque
la construction va dépendre un petit peu
de l'environnement économique du loyer
c'est donc de notre travail c'est de
faire quelque chose qui soit le plus
fonctionnel rationnelle et surtout
identitaire également donc tout ce
travail là nous le faisons tous ensemble
et c'est un
ce talent parcours identitaire c'est à
dire qu'en fait l'entreprise elle veut
que ce bâtiment lui ressemble mais ça
ils font ça en compte que ce soit
vraiment à l'abri
c'est à dire que marc oui bien sûr donc
toujours en fonction du contexte et il
faut que l'on essaye avant tout
l'immeuble d'être rationnelle et
fonctionnelle mais ensuite on de lui
apporter une identité et cette identité
le toutes les personnes qui vont
travailler à un accord dans l'intérêt de
l'entreprise vont s'y attacher il ya une
certaine je crois qu'on peut y aller à
des fiertés à tous les collaborateurs
d'une entreprise vaut un siège qui a une
forte identité à venir travailler à
venir montrer et ses affaires d'état de
deux réunions à l'intérieur de façon à
montrer le dynamisme de l'entreprise par
l'image que l'on peut avoir du siège
social
vous avez reçu australia qui est devenu
un bâtiment assez important on voit ces
images là bâtiment rouge là aussi choisi
mexico choix de la couleur n'est pas
anodin là aussi c'est vraiment
représente représentatif de weeds c'est
à dire vous le constatez comme ça alors
l'écriture architecturale ne vient pas
comme ça de d'une idée
l'idée doit toujours être fondées et en
particulier sur ce programme là c'était
une expérience qui était très
intéressant puisqu'il a été conçu avant
grenelle de l'environnement et toute la
démarche que voulait faire le groupe oui
c'était de d'anticiper un petit peu sur
tout ce qui serait les nouvelles
techniques de construction et surtout
l'école et toutes les techniques
d'économie d'énergie que l'on allait
développer dans les années suivantes
puisque donc je le rappelle avant le
grenelle de l'environnement
beaucoup de technique n'est qu'il existe
aujourd'hui n'existaient pas à l'époque
et ce qui a été très intéressant sur ce
programme c'est que autour de la table
pour la conception le groupe bouygues
avait plusieurs
je veux dire plusieurs identités
également puisqu'elle est il était
également donc un v6 qu'ils étaient
constructeur il était promoteurs il
allait être utilisateurs et surtout ils
allaient être gestionnaire
c'est à dire que ce projet là il a été
raisonné si vous voulez en coût global
quand on parle de coût global ça veut
dire que cet immeuble à il a été pensé
sur une économie de gestion et
d'utilisation sur pratiquement trente
ans donc on a travaillé sur la
rationalité de façon à ce qu'on puisse
accueillir tel ou tel service de
l'entreprise
et comme on voit les techniques évoluent
considérablement et donc il faut qu'on
puisse accueillir toutes ces techniques
quelle que soit l'année durant laquelle
ce bâtiment donc va vivre donc tout ce
travail là nous l'avons fait ensemble et
ça a été un travail passionnant puisque
ça nous a permis nous d'avoir d'autres
orientations de recherche sur
l'évolution de l'immobilier tertiaire et
puis surtout sur tout ce qui était
économies d'énergie compréhension dans
un premier temps faire cette émission
que les tous côtés aussi obsolète qu'il
fallait donc on comprend bien vous il
faut anticiper pour être alors catherine
raynaud on va parler avec vous du
développement durable parce que je vois
ça fait partie de l'adn
il s'est i le votre moteur historique de
saint quentin en yvelines
comment ça se traduit dans l'immobilier
parce qu'on a bien complexe évolué il
fallait évoluer toujours avec lui - dont
clim'city on porte même dans notre nom
maintenant cette notion de développement
le quartier le lien c'est c'est une de
nos spécificités au delà d'être un
promoteur classique sur une parcelle un
bâtiment on travaille beaucoup ce qu'on
appelle chez nous le multi produits le
multi usages
jusqu'aujourd'hui un bâtiment il n'est
pas tout seul il doit pas être penser
connecter à la ville il doit s'inscrire
dans un écosystème où on vit on
travaille on consomme on s'éduque et le
bâtiment ne doit pas être fermé sur
lui-même il doit aussi s'ouvrir sur
d'autres usages pour le bien-être de
tous les habitants d'un quartier et
c'est ce qui se fait dans le quartier du
vélodrome c'est en tout cas c'est ce que
vous avez tenté de mettre en place alors
le quartier du vélodrome est un des
premiers quartiers sur lesquels on a
travaillé sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines le fait générateur
et l arrivée de l'équipement sportif
qu'est le vélodrome la communauté
d'agglo voilà nous a demandé de
travailler à créer autour de ce
vélodrome et bien une vie donc on a
travaillé avec eux elle était très
important puisque au delà de savoir qui
on voulait mettre sur ce quartier
vous devez aussi travaillé l'aspect
urbain réglementaire et ç'a vraiment été
en travaillant en binôme avec les
services de la communauté d'agglo pour
écrire le règlement d'urbanisme qui
permettait d'accueillir donc
essentiellement des étudiants des
chercheurs
des hôtels s'est exclusivement dédiée
effectivement a duré des anciennes gérer
puisque c'était à ce moment-là ce que la
ville souhaitait sur son territoire
alors bien sûr vous on l'a vu aussi dans
le corpus de crédit agricole c'est
important qu'ils aient des espaces verts
c'est important ça numérique
vous êtes un peu porteur aussi de cette
nouvelle dynamique tout à fait alors une
nouvelle dynamique oui encore une fois
on a on a souhaité faire un campus
technologique du groupe
la notion si développement durable est
importante pour noah faut pas oublier
qu'on est la banque verte donc la
construction c'est forcément
construction avec le label haute qualité
environnementale
un rénovation selon les labels bbc
rénovation puis l'exploitation ensuite
du campus en hq donc autre qualité
environnementale au niveau
d'exploitation si donc on est très porté
sur le développement durable
et puis aussi bas nos collaborateurs
sont tous les jours confronté avec les
nouvelles technologies donc c'est un
être qu'on a voulu développer encore une
fois sur ce campus en fait un vrai
campus technologique des moyens de
paiement et des opérations bancaires
boudées
vous aviez dit quand on a préparé cette
émission que c'était une évidence qu'il
fallait que ça soit numérique connecté
mais est-ce que l'immobilier
d'entreprise poids se fait une nouvelle
dynamique à vue tout à fait parce que là
par exemple nous changeons complètement
certains quartiers alors en dehors avant
d'aborder tous les problèmes techniques
les nouvelles technologies qui doivent
s'intégrer nature les bâtiments il est
certain que nous nous devons arriver à
dynamiser donc certains quartiers et ça
ça peut se faire également grâce au
jeudi aux orientations tout à fait
astucieuse et intelligente qu'ont pu
avoir les
et les différents présidents de la
communauté d'agglo à saint quentin ainsi
que les maires qui nous ont permis par
la modification des règlements
d'urbanisme comme l'a évoqué les 6,2 me
regarde tout à l'heure ça nous a permis
si vous voulez de changer complètement
certains quartiers notamment nous nous
travaillons également sur un campus sur
le pas du lac et sur sur un ensemble de
immobilier qui était donc année années
soixante dix années 80 les immeubles
étaient complètement obsolète
on ne pouvait plus rien en faire et les
règlements nous ont permis donc comme
cela avait été évoqué donc de densifier
mais surtout qu'on a requalifié d'un
point de vue en vain l'ensemble du
quartier aux bénéfices non seulement des
riverains mais surtout des personnes qui
vont vivre à l'intérieur de ces
immeubles et à l'avenir du campus donc
si vous voulez on a densifié on a
augmenté le nombre de mètres carrés nous
ne sommes pas allés à l'extrême de ce
que l'on pouvait faire puisqu'on pouvait
toujours faire du qualitatif toujours
pour le bien-être des personnes qui
vivent à l'intérieur
donc si vous voulez on travaille sur du
neuf est sûre de la réhabilitation
lourde sur des immeubles sur des
immeubles qui était auparavant donc dans
les secteurs à requalifier complètement
donc le skate évoqué également tout à
l'heure c'est que nous devons aller
également plus loin en ce sens que
l'immeuble de bureaux à pouvoir
accueillir non seulement des techniques
nouvelles que vous l'avez évoqué mais il
doit et vous il doit pouvoir accueillir
je lirai différentes façons de
travailler si ak l'intérieur d'une
entreprise sur les différents projets
qu'elles peuvent savoir qui arrive en
fonction des contrats qui arrivent de
l'étranger
il ya différents projets qui demandent à
ce que des personnes soient ensemble
soit de façon individuelle soit en
groupe travail éventuellement avec du
matériel qui est très important ou pas
donc nous no no no plateau doivent être
adaptées à ce genre de situation et qui
plus est pouvoir est transformé
également comme ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure en logement et donc là des
difficultés elle est là c'est qu'on
s'est rendu compte que les rénovations
plan fait à l'heure actuelle des îles au
delà des 70 les les immeubles étaient
tout à fait à lui dire mal mal français
à cette époque et dont nous nous devons
tenir compte toutes ces erreurs passées
et essayer d'avoir quelque chose qui
soit le plus souple possible pour
pouvoir accueillir quelques programmes
que ce soit la nature des constructions
que nous faisons aujourd'hui
alors voilà donc annie mobile est plus
souple plus adaptable catherine raynaud
vous vous plaidez pour l'immobilier
d'usagé qu'est ce que c'est ça rejoint
peu ce que dit ce que dit hubert c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui quand on quand on
vient dans un immeuble pour retravailler
on peut aussi vouloir un moment faire
une pause pour se restaurer faire une
pause pour autre chose où il y
accueillir d'autres d'autres fonctions
donc
qui viennent de l'extérieur les exemples
les plus classiques les pieds
d'immeubles sont souvent dédiés à des
restaurants d'entreprise qui fonctionne
qu'entre midi et deux heures le reste du
temps c'est vide donc on doit pouvoir
trouver un autre usage assez à ces
espaces qui vont servir peut-être à des
associations extérieures a du coup orkin
à pourquoi pas un restaurateur quelqu'un
qui vient faire une animation
particulière voilà d'autres exemples
sont aussi l' usage du stationnement
c'est quelque chose qu'on attaque de
plus en plus partagé le parking des
parkings de logements sur toujours envie
de la journée les parkings de bureau
sont aujourd'hui de la nuit et pourtant
on continue à faire les deux donc lusage
partage et du stationnement est aussi
une évolution dans laquelle on doit
aller à la paix il faut encore
convaincre ça c'est toujours un peu
complexe nous convaincre les personnes
les particuliers peut-être de prêter au
boulou et laure leur parking pour
prendre cet exemple
alors on parler d'innovation il ya
l'innovation peut aussi passer par un
centre commercial
on va regarder de suite l'open sky qui
doit ouvrir à plaisir alors ça crée
beaucoup de discussions et c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment un projet très
innovant on regarde la galerie des
sablons situé à plaisir va subir un
lifting de grande ampleur le permis de
construire du nouveau centre commercial
open sky vient d'être signé l'annoncé a
été faite pendant la cérémonie de voeux
du maire de la commune joséphine coleman
ce berger ça c'est une zone qui est en
friche
aujourd'hui et c'est un endroit qui
méritent véritablement qu'on mette en
place quelque chose de qualitatif
le projet comprendra trente deux mille
mètres carrés de commerces 35 magasins
six restaurants et un cinéma d'une
dizaine de salles vont sortir de terre
clairement il y adeux je pense qu'il ya
de la part d'eads et des habitants de
plaisir une certaine demande pour
quelque chose de nouveau
ici à cet endroit qui remplacerait ce
bâtiment qu'il faut bien le dire est
aujourd'hui un très beau ce qui nous
ferait plaisir c'est que quand ils le
voient terminée
quand ils vont entrer dedans le disent
juste war le projet était attendue par
les plaisirs roi depuis une dizaine
d'années avant il y avait un magasin de
cuisine il y avait enfin il y avait tout
ça fait il y avait beaucoup d'activité
et puis maintenant c'est pourquoi il
faudrait mieux qu'on rénove un peu
depuis le temps qu'on l'attend ça va
peut-être faire n'importe comment parler
pour ceux qui sont déjà là ils en ont
marre parce que même les ascenseurs
fonctionnent pas les travaux devraient
débuter cette année pour une livraison
prévue avant la fin 2018 le nouveau
centre sera présenté aux plaisirs oit le
18 février prochain l'espace coluche de
plaisir
rénové rénover c'est un peu le mettre au
moins on l'aura compris en plus en
apportant de nouvelles et une nouvelle
dynamique vers vous dites est dans
l'action à ce projet assez il faut à
tout prix donc redonner une nouvelle une
nouvelle image et puis surtout une
nouvelle fonctionnalité à tous ses
programmes notamment commerciaux on nous
paie pression' helmand nous n'avons pas
de programme de cette taille mais en
effet je trouve que l'identité de cette
soixante commercial et est assez
intéressante mais ça ça va toujours dans
la dynamique de de toute la communauté
saint quentin je trouve que
il faut féliciter la de dynamisme des
élus et ensuite de la communauté d'agglo
parce que ça je pense que pour faire
évoluer tous nos projets on peut pas
faire ça seul et la point de vue je dire
d'un point de vue administratif tout le
travail qu'ils font avec nous est
toujours très intéressant et très
positif pour nous faire pour nous faire
évoluer faire annoncer rapidement les
choses
oui le terme de facilitateur et donc le
choisit catherine rey novosti une
réaction à ce complexe à vous disait que
vraiment c'était la bonne
la bonne solution il faut se lancer dans
de tels projets effectivement le
commerce et aussi comme le bureau est en
train de repenser ce qu'il peut apporter
au consommateur on vient plus seulement
faire un achat on vient aussi passer un
moment en famille se divertir se
cultiver et les nouveaux centres
commerciaux intègre beaucoup cette ce
paramètre et en l'occurrence l'opérateur
qui va rénover ce sont deux commerciales
à plaisir est un des précurseurs dans ce
domaine
julien chevaux alors vous serez axéens
peut-être un petit peu éloigné de te
fait crédit agricole immobilier mais
c'est vrai que là aussi on l'a expliqué
quand je parlais de rénovation vous
c'est un problème auquel vous êtes
confrontés parce que là aussi le premier
campus date de 1916 et c'est important
dit aussi vous avez choisi que de tout
refaire comment ça s'est passé
wima une nouvelle vie parce que
parce que tout change les modes de
travail évoluent les nouvelles
générations arrivent beaucoup de
technologies arrivent aussi donc il
fallait qu'on donne aux 6,7 centimes ce
sentiment et cette identité du campus
pour que pour que les gens soient fiers
de travailler sur 50 ans donc on a voulu
faire table rase du passé repenser les
espaces beaucoup plus ouvert la mixité
des espaces quoi une fois il faut que
les gens travaillent mais il faut qu'ils
puissent aussi décompresser se restaurer
on a mis en place une conciergerie la
salle de sport tous ces équipements font
que on souhaite que collaborateurs se
sentent bien dans son espace de travail
soient contents de travailler sur ce
campus pour pour être plus performant
puis après c'est vrai qu'on a un cadre
de vie ici qui est très très agréable
donc il faut en profiter ou même dans
les centres commerciaux on essaie de là
aussi avoir un cadre de vie qui dépasse
le simple commerce entre et là je la
semaine dernière je voyais le président
de la chaussure que nous avons fait sur
saint quentin et ce qui était très
intéressant c'était de voir la volonté
qu'ils avaient de d'ouvrir même son
siège social à des personnes de
l'extérieur et ensuite d'étaler
également la façon de travailler à
l'intérieur des immeubles d'ailleurs que
les horaires étaient une souplesse la
plus totale donc ce qui permettait donc
d'utiliser les bureaux le plus longtemps
possible dans le temps et c'est ce qu'il
voulait de façon à dynamiser puis à ce
point de vue même culture interne de
l'entreprise tous ses collaborateurs
puissent ouvrir au maximum sur
l'extérieur il souhaitait même avoir la
possibilité d'intégrer des startups qui
n'était pas de l'entreprise les
personnes externes de les faire rentrer
dans l'entreprise de façon à ce que ça
puisse créer de l'émulation donc nous il
faut que l'angle la recherche
architecturale et dans les plateaux ou
dans le concept que nous avons on doit
s'adapter au maximum justement tout
c'est serré organisation de l'entreprise
et puis de l'utilisation des espaces
alors est-ce que c'est l'immobilier sera
ma dernière question est-ce que c'est
l'immobilier d'entreprise qui
influencent l'immobilier en général
ou comment ça se passe en fait parce que
là on dit que effectivement son travail
d'une autre façon peut-être qu'on aura
envie d'avoir une
dans ce qu'ils soient différentes
hausses et c'est possible mais je pense
que la fois la révolution et l'évolution
à partir de l'umih entreprises est
beaucoup plus dynamique que celle que
l'on peut avoir
je veux dire dans l'habitat résidentiel
d'accord mais aussi les séquences de
temps qu'on attend d'une journée sont de
plus en plus poreuses
on travaille on vit de façon plus
continue et on doit pouvoir dans chacun
des espaces pouvoir répondre un petit
peu à tout ça et on voit que le logement
évolué l'immobilier d'entreprise évolue
le commerce évolue mais tout le monde
dans une démarche de multiplicité comme
ça des usages pour chacun merci vraiment
à vous trois d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
grâce à vous on en sait un peu plus sur
l'immobilier d'entreprise on a bien
compris que ça a soufflé une dynamique
sur le territoire et que surtout c'était
qu'il fallait que ça soit vraiment que
ça corresponde à nos attentes
vous retrouvez votre merci à vous encore
une fois les maintenant place à notre
agenda
rendez vous donc le 14 avril à 18h30 au
vélodrome pour les rencontres de
l'innovation apii innove c'est la
première du genre le réseau open innove
relance en octobre dernier contre déjà
200 membres et ils vont pour la première
fois pouvoir se rencontrer attention le
dress code est assez particulier puisque
on vous demande de venir en jeans et
baskets voilà c'est le côté happy in
love
alors si vous avez envie d'en savoir
plus sur la ligne 18 du métro
automatique du grand paris un important
les transports on l'a redit lors de
cette émission
une réunion publique d'information aura
lieu le 14 avril à guyancourt au
pavillon où elle décroche soasta 20h30
l'enquète publique est ouverte jusqu'au
19 avril enfin si vous êtes étudiant es
ou entrepreneurs ne ratez pas à
l'atelier développement du 27 avril
atelier qui se tiendra à 9 de 9h30 à 11h
à la maison de l'entreprise
au programme focus et solutions pour
créer votre job
et justement entreprendre ce sera le
thème de notre prochaine émission
d'ici là bah écoutez je vous laisse
regarder tv fil 78 et je vous donne
rendez-vous donc pour un prochain film
est co consacrée à ce thème qui nous
intéresse tous entreprendre encore merci
à vous trois d'être venu d'avoir
participé à cette émission à très vite
est resté sur téléfilm ici